it's a busy weekend as high school
students march stormy Daniels comes
clean and tariff talk dominates the
economy we'll get to all of it I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
okay folks I promise not everything I
say today will be a sexual pun with
regard to a scandal about a pornstar I
will attempt to make only 73 percent of
all the things I say some sort of double
entendre or pun because we have to be
serious about it sorry I can't even make
it through that well get to all this
stuff but first I want to say thank you
to our sponsors over at quip so when it
comes to your health you got to know
that your tooth health actually your
mouth health actually makes a big
difference to your generalized health in
fact gum health has a lot to do with
heart disease believe it or not and
there's only one way to ensure that you
are getting the cleanest possible mouth
and that is with quip that is because
quip is the new electric toothbrush that
packs just the right amount of vibration
into a slimmer design at a fraction of
the cost of bulkier electronic truth
brushes and guiding pulses alert you as
to when to switch sides you're not
spending too little time makes brushing
the right amount just effortless it also
comes the mount that sticks right to
your mirror and unsticks to use as a
cover for hygienic travel anywhere
whether it's going in your gym bag or
your carry-on and because the thing that
cleans your mouth should also be clean
quips subscription plan refreshes your
brush on a dentist recommended schedule
so they deliver a new brush to you every
three months for just five bucks a new
brush head rather to every three months
for just five bucks including free
shipping worldwide so you never have to
worry about you've been using the same
brush head for the last eight months
quip is backed by a network of over
10,000 dental professionals including
dentist hygienist and dental students
most toothbrushes don't get named on
times Best Inventions that's because
most aren't as good as quit right now
quip starts at 25 bucks in if you go to
get quipped calm slash Schapiro you'll
get your first refill pack free with a
quip electric toothbrush that's get quip
comm slash Shapiro you get your first
refill pack free with a quip electric
toothbrush again get quip comm slash
Shapiro GE tqu IP comm slash apparel
make sure that you're as healthy as can
be in your mouth is as healthy as it
should be again get quip comm slash
Shapiro to get that special deal and let
them know that we sent you as well
alright so the news cycle began over the
weekend with this big March for our
lives that happened in Washington DC now
approximately 200,000 people showed up
in large for our lives it's a good
number it's a solid number in the March
for Life in 2012 had 650,000 people who
showed up to it was the media coverage
blanket the way that it was on Saturday
now listen I don't think that this is
about the kids at Parkland kids are kids
some of them say smart things some of
them say dumb things and just be
has some tragedy fell upon them doesn't
mean that they suddenly have expertise
on guns for example but the main issue
here is why the media have decided to
highlight and spotlight these kids and
the reason is because the kids can say
things that the media can hide behind
the high school kids who don't really
know much about guns don't know much
about gun control but can speak with
passion and Verve and are attractive on
camera they can say things that the
media want to say but know that they
would be bashed about the ears for
saying because they are supposed to be
objective and so what the media do
instead is they put all of these kids on
camera for hours at a time and then
claim that if you criticize what these
kids are saying they are actually
criticizing the experience of
experiences of these kids this is
another form of identity politics so
identity politics is this idiotic
concept from the left that suggests that
we can identify the quality of your
perspective simply by the color of your
skin or your ethnicity or your age or
some immutable characteristic about
yourself well in this particular case
the suggestion is that the opinions of
these kids are sacrosanct because these
kids experience tragedy I'm not
questioning whether these kids
experienced tragedy they did but I am
questioning whether their perspectives
have any additional value because they
experienced tragedy George Soros went
through the Holocaust right here's a guy
who ended up having to help the Nazis in
order to survive I can still say that I
think all of his political perspectives
are shared garbage and it doesn't mean
that I'm criticizing George Soros his
experiences in the Holocaust and the
same thing is true for these kids okay
and the the stuff the kids were saying
was just pretty egregious one of the
things they were doing is they were
carrying around these tags these price
tags that said on it one dollar and five
sons in order to criticize Senator Marco
Rubio now senator Rubio put himself out
there in front of a town hall of baying
baying angry people in order to try and
make some sort of come to some sort of
agreement and solution with people in
Florida over what to do to protect kids
safety and instead he's been just
clubbed around so these kids were
wearing around taxes at dollar and five
cents why because if you take the
receipts that Marco Rubio has had from
the NRA and you average it over the
number of students in the state of
Florida it comes out to a dollar and
five cents for each student their
suggestion is that Marco Rubio is being
paid off a dollar and five cents for
every student the state of Florida be
pro-gun
that's disgusting it's not true it's a
lie it's it's malicious obviously it's
stupid if you think that Marco Rubio is
pro-gun because
the NRA Gizem with 5,000 bucks you're
out of your mind yeah the idea that the
Marco Rubio is sitting around waiting
for the NRA to sign a cheque and then he
decides to be pro-gun is insulting I
find this whole line of argument really
stupid I found it stupid when it was
being pushed by John McCain his campaign
finance reform I find it stupid now
politicians generally don't support
causes because they're being bribed by
constituents they support causes and
then the people who back those causes
pay so those people can get into office
it's not like if you thought that the
NRA was just going around bribing people
why is it the Democrats aren't able to
be bribed why is it the NRA can't go to
Democrats and bribe them is it because
Democrats are such upstanding characters
or is it because Democrats are pure gun
control fanatics and the NRA doesn't
want to see them elected but again this
is all part of the dog and pony show to
suggest that people who disagree on gun
control are actually bad human beings
and so we're gonna go through some of
the arguments that were being made by a
lot of the kids at this at this rally
because I think that it's important to
look at the arguments not just at the
speaker's well the media want us to see
are the still photos of David hog with
his arm outstretched or Emma Gonzales
standing there silently and then we're
supposed to say well anything these
people choose to say must be right again
I have nothing but sympathy for what
they went through yeah I have sympathy
for what Kyle cashew is a conservative
student went through all these kids went
through something but it doesn't mean
their experiences confer any sort of
expertise upon them okay so we start
with David hog David hog has been the
most ubiquitous member of the of the
cadre of classmates
he's been on virtually every TV show
he's done Ellen he does CNN on a regular
basis he does the sunday shows he
doesn't know anything about guns he
doesn't know much about gun control but
he certainly knows how to demagogue and
so for four minutes you'll hear him
demagogue over and over and over in the
most traumatic fashion and it's it's
irritating to watch I understand
particularly for people who are pro
Second Amendment but it's important to
know what what the propagandist in the
media are doing with this kid because
again the kid can speak out it's his
it's his absolute right to speak out and
obviously he can speak in front of any
camera that he wants to speak in front
of that's great but he can be criticized
just like anyone else I know I was 17 I
wrote a syndicated column I got
criticized just like everybody else
that's the way free speech works in the
country okay here is David Hogg we're
gonna go through his full speech or as
much of it as possible first off I'm
gonna start off by putting this price
tag right here as a reminder for you
to know how much Marco Rubio took for
every student's life in Florida one
dollar and five cents okay that is a lie
deposit right there again that's a lie
okay then the dollar and five cent thing
is a slander against Marco Rubio it's
disgusting and by the way if you want to
actually come to some sort of agreement
about what we can do here you might want
to start by talking to the senator from
Florida who's actually proposed
legislation with bill Nelson on
protecting schools this is not designed
to help anybody this is designed to
virtue signal and it's designed in order
so the Democrats can feel better about
themselves okay hog continues grasp of
corruption shackles the District of
Columbia the winter is over change is
here the Sun shines on a new day and the
day is ours I don't know that means the
prayer first time voters show up 18% of
the time in midterm elections not
anymore
money we don't know the stats gets out
there's now who here is gonna vote in
the 2018 election if you listen real
close you can hear the people in power
shaking
well you've gotten used to being
protective of their position chewing
safety the safety of inaction inaction
is no longer safe and to that we say no
more okay pause right there for one
second okay I just wanna point something
out the generic ballot over the weekend
close to about five points had been up
to twelve I believe one of the reasons
it's closing is because Republicans are
looking at this kind of demagoguery and
they're saying final gotten vote before
the question was would Republicans go
out and vote in any significant numbers
and there is no reason to think
Republicans what it's an off-year
election there's no real galvanizing
issue you want to galvanize Republicans
tell them that you're gonna take away
their guns that they're evil people who
want to murder children if they don't
let you take away their guns you don't
know why the gap that ballot gap is
closing it's because every time the
media decide to go on a crusade against
Second Amendment rights they're a bunch
of Americans say fine I'll finally get
off my Duff and go vote okay so before
David Hogg declares victory especially
on the gun control issue you should
recognize a couple of things one
Democrats in power have not passed any
gun control Barack Obama has zero gun
control between 2009 and 2011 when he
had full control of Congress and two
Republicans are actually gonna show up
in broader numbers thanks to this sort
of demagoguery than they would otherwise
here we can continue
96 people 96 people die every day from
guns in our country yet most
representatives have no public stance ok
pause it for one second okay first of
all 96 people die in our country every
day 66 of those people die from suicide
ok 2/3 of all the people who are lumped
into the gun violence statistics are
suicides second of all the vast majority
of people who are killed with guns in
the United States are killed with
handguns the proposals that have been
pushed by March for our live students
have nothing to do with handguns they
have to do with ar-15s and so-called
assault rifles
ok so none of this makes any sense on a
policy level continue and tonight we say
no voting issue we're going to make take
this to every election to every state in
every city we're going to make sure the
best people get in our elections to run
not as politicians but as Americans
because this this is not cutting it when
people try to suppress your vote and who
stands against you because you're too
young we say no more when politicians
say that your voice doesn't matter
because the NRA owns them we say no ok
so we can stop it there I don't need to
listen the rest of this ok so first of
all the yelling and the screaming I know
that a lot of young kids who think that
when they do this that this is actually
just showing passion on the podium it
doesn't it just it's it's not convincing
it doesn't make people like you it
doesn't make people rally behind you in
fact calm this and reason actually make
people rally behind you more than
screaming from the podium again this
whole thing that the NRA owns
politicians it's just not true but I
guess that that's not the point the
point here is of course the demagogue
the issue as much as humanly possible it
wasn't just david hog who did this at
the end of it he he gave sort of a
revolution symbol the person who did
this the best actually I will say Emma
Gonzales is the most skilled politician
of these kids Emma Gonzalez went up
there
she spoke for about a minute 20 and then
she did a 5 minute just standing break
right she stood there and she said in
tribute to my classmates moment of
silence in the moment of silence lasted
for five minutes and then at 6 minutes
20 seconds she said that's how long the
shooting in our school
lasted that was effective theatrics and
she's actually good at this David hog
not particularly good at this Cameron
cask is another one of the students from
Parkland and here's what he had to say
again this sort of language is not going
to endear you to people you have to make
agreements with on the issue of gun
control to the leaders skeptics and
cynics who told us to sit down and say
stay silent wait your turn
welcome to the revolution okay if you
want to if you want to see our gun
owners into going out and vote tell them
it's a revolution to take their guns see
how that's gonna go see how it goes when
you tell a bunch of gun owners that it's
a revolution to take away their firearms
which is really what they're talking
about here again all this stuff is great
fodder for media members is not great
fodder for actually fostering any sort
of victory on the issue of protecting
schools by the way the chance of being
killed in a school shooting I believe in
the United States are stumbling one in
six hundred and fourteen million in any
case let's talk a little bit about our
sponsors over at stamps.com so these
days you can get practically everything
you want on demand well that hadn't been
true of stamps and the stuff you get at
the post office until now with stamps
calm you can access all the amazing
services are the post office right from
your desk 24/7 whenever it is convenient
for you you can buy and print US postage
for any letter any package using your
own computer and printer you print it
out right onto a sticker or you print it
out right onto the envelope or you print
it on a piece of paper and you tape it
to the envelope and then the mail
carrier picks it up you click print mail
you're done it's very very easy and here
at the Daily wire we use it all the time
in order to send our mail because we
don't want to spend time in the line of
the post office no matter how much we
like the post office you should use
stamps calm as well you can also ensure
that you have exact postage so you're
not estimating right you're not home and
you're sticking eight stamps when you
only need 6 stamps ok because they will
send you a postage meter as well with
our special offer so right now use
Shapiro for this special offer
ok includes up to fifty five dollars of
free postage and the digital scale and a
four week trial so go to stamps calm
before you do anything else click on the
radio mic at the top of the homepage you
type in Shapiro that stamps comm enter
promo code Shapiro and you get $55 a
free postage a digital scale and a
four-week trial it's a pretty
spectacular offer again stamps calm
promo code Shapiro fantastic service we
use it at the office all the time use
that promo code shape here to get the
special deal when you when you click out
at micro the microphone at the top of
the page use promo code Shapiro and then
ensure that you that they know that we
sent you as well as getting
okay so back to these kids so again the
reason I'm going through the litany of
claims by these by these high school
kids is because I want to show that they
haven't even bothered to do the research
and again these kids didn't say whatever
they want it's not their fault they're
17 I get it okay I was 17 - I was
reading a syndicated column on politics
I don't agree with everything I wrote
when I was 17 because who does but the
media is proclaiming these are fully
formed adults capable of leading the
debate on gun control when the vast
majority of them obviously don't know
anything about gun control here's
another one of these students alex wins
so Alex Wynne says you know there are
too many people here who want to arm
teachers and then he makes what it would
be an incredibly it is talking about
arming Mickey Mouse and I love all the
cheering people like what is he even
saying making that first of all how
could Mickey Mouse even get that out of
his costume
okay those pants aren't real on the
Mickey Mouse costume he does actually
have pockets does he have a shoulder
holster holster Mickey Mouse yeah I've
been to Disney Land recently okay Mickey
Mouse has nowhere to hide that that
sucker like ever gonna have anybody at
Disney Land packing heat it's got to be
like the characters from Mary Poppins at
least they're wearing jackets or
something but Mickey Mouse can't even
get inside that costume so there's no
logic to this one but again what do I
want my rabbi packing heat you bet your
ass I want my rabbi packing heat okay my
synagogue is one of the most likely
places in America to be targeted number
one cuz it's synagogue and number two
cuz there's a lot of people who know I
go to this synagogue so you know that
yes I want everyone packing heat at my
synagogue yes yes I wish my rabbi could
pack heat I think Minister should pack
heat ask them to ask the minister at the
in the Texas Church shooting ask the
ministers in in South Carolina in
Charleston during the church shooting
whether it would been better if the
minister were packing heat the answer is
yes that would have been much better if
people were packing heat so I don't even
understand this argument the argument is
that less if fewer people should pack
heat okay just just to show you how dumb
this is do we have that video of the
kids leaving the rally
okay so here's some video of the kids
leaving the rally these are the same
kids who just said they don't want
everybody packing heat a lot of these
kids have said they don't want
additional school security see if you
can notice something weird about this
video
hey watch hey we'll watch them right now
is a bunch of kids who are walking by
right these are all the high school kids
and they're being ushered out by a bunch
of security members and Wow look at that
one of the security members carrying why
it looks as though they are armed and
carrying guns what the high school
students at a gun control march aren't
being protected by people carrying guns
why that would seem ironic and crazy the
same people claiming how dare anyone say
that we need more armed security in
schools we'll say we need to armed
security for this March pretty pretty
amazing stuff so just brilliant to show
a little more of the additional
brilliance here are some of the signs
that were that were shown so let's go
through these one is freedom more
important than safety is something that
legitimately one of these people is
holding is freedom more important than
safety okay um did any of these kids
have like a basic any in any sense these
can have any sort of basic American
education is freedom more important than
safety yes yes freedom is more important
than safety okay in fact Benjamin
Franklin actually had a specific quote
on this in which he said that any people
who gives up safety who gives up a
little bit of freedom for safety will
end up with neither safety nor freedom a
very very famous quote by Benjamin
Franklin in fact the second the American
Revolution was largely fought on the
basis that freedom was more important
than safety resistance to any
dictatorship is based on the idea that
freedom freedom is more important than
safety so this sign is stupid let's have
another stupid sign let's see here's
that this one was particularly great
this one says my uterus is more is more
restricted than your gun right it says
something like my uterus is is let's see
if we have all of them is more regulated
than your guns is what this entire thing
says okay number one this is untrue you
can actually use your uterus to kill
people you can't use your gun to kill
people in the United States legally so
there's that also I assume that most
women do not actually do like a federal
background check before they allow use
of their uterus so there's that as well
I don't think that some of these people
are checking ID even before use of the
uterus is allowed so that's a weird sign
so well done everybody there and here is
a final one it says F the NRA
and so here's a question did any of the
kids at this at this rally hold signs
saying F the shooter is a point made by
Cameron
Twitter the answer of course is no yeah
the stupidity doesn't end there here is
a Cameron Cassie again this is one of
the students who you saw speaking a
little bit earlier saying that it's not
shooters that make shootings happen it's
weapons that make shootings happen fact
that nobody is disco in the bill they
don't say the word gun once what causes
all these shootings what's the one thing
to tie everything together there's no
specific mental health problem that
makes all these shootings happen it's
the weapon and the fact that they aren't
taking any action towards it is proof
that we need to keep on going ok when
they say it's the weapon the the the
most deadly school shooting in the
United States we actually took place in
Virginia Tech 32 people were killed a
handgun was used those are not the guns
that people are talking about and if
we're gonna talk about comorbidity
between gun ownership and school
shootings it's actually really really
low 100 million Americans who own guns
the number of school shootings in the
United States is very low from the
number compared to the number of people
who own guns obviously you know the
comorbidity is actually I would assume a
lot higher between the number of
shooters and the number of people who
severe for who suffer from severe mental
illness okay in any case the statistics
are really low just because the sample
size is so small for school shootings
but if we're gonna use statistical
analysis and we're gonna say that the
common factor is the guns I would say
the more of the common factor when it
comes to these issues is is the mental
illness at least in so far as the
general population percentage of the
general population that owns guns or has
mental illness performing these school
shootings and well so one of the things
that's been happening is is finally the
media have started to pay attention to
some of the other students now Kyle
cashew who's I know a listener to the
program and I've advised him a little
bit on the side Kyle the student over at
the Marjory Stoneman Douglas high school
and and Kyle was finally on Face the
Nation now the media have been saying
that look you guys claim that we're
biased but we're having on people like
Kyle we're having on some people who are
pro Second Amendment right after we
shamed you into it after Twitter didn't
verify Kyle for four weeks after I
highlighted Kyle after I personally
started pushing for people to pay
attention to Kyle people started paying
attention to Kyle that's great it's a
little late okay Kyle final he's been
verified but the media have not had him
on any of the show that he was supposed
to be on CNN the other day and CNN
wouldn't have him on because he had said
nasty things about about one of the CNN
hoes because that CNN host had been
allowing bad
Marco Rubio for no apparent reason it
finally caught us a lot on Face the
Nation and Kyle knows these issues a lot
better than his peers he's challenged at
least a couple of his peers to debate
but nobody's actually gonna hold that
CNN is not gonna have a debate between
Kyle Kashyap and Cameron Caskey or Kyle
kasev and David hog it ain't gonna
happen
here is Kyle talking on Face the Nation
making what I think is a much more
intelligent case with regard to gun
control talk to senators and I looked at
all the facts and they all point in the
same direction that a ban on assault
weapons will not solve this issue
it's simply ohm and restrictions on
high-capacity magazines that won't solve
the issue what we've seen is that there
are certain things such as having
enforcing the regulation that's
currently in law I mean we've seen on so
many different levels that the cowards
of broward failed the FBI failed sheriff
Scott Israel failed so many different
multi-layered levels failed okay and of
course he's exactly right the media have
ignored all of the specific
circumstances surrounding the shootings
they can talk about guns more broadly
they do this all the time when JFK was
shot they suggested that the real issue
was not that JFK was shot by a communist
but that it was race relations in the
United States that were more broadly
responsible for JFK's shooting the left
will always swivel from the actual facts
of any given scenario in order to reach
out to what their agenda actually is and
they'll ignore people who have something
to say in the process
Patrick petty is is the brother of one
of the people who was shot in in the
shooting and and he tweeted out at Emma
Gonzales who mentioned his sister quote
hey Emma please stop using my sister's
name to push her agenda she did not and
would not support it okay that's it not
get any nearly the amount media coverage
as Emma Gonzalez is speech did of course
because this is more about media bias
than it is about anything else well in
just a second I'm gonna talk about
stormy Daniels but first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at
Skillshare so Skillshare is the best way
for you to broaden and deepen your
resume right in today's job market
turnover is really high it means that
you're probably gonna be seeking a job
sometime in the next three to five years
and that means that you have to
constantly be improving your skill set
that you are ahead of the curve and
ahead of your competitors
well Skillshare is the place to do it
it's an online learning platform with
over 18,000 classes in design business
technology and more you can take classes
in graphic design social media marketing
illustration mobile photography you name
it they've got it all of them are taught
by experts and if you're trying to
deepen your professional skill set this
is the best way to do it we at the
office have been taking these classes
search engine optimization and social
media marketing we've been taking
classes I took a watercolor class from
Skillshare join the millions of students
already learning on Skillshare today
with a special offer just for my
listeners right now you get two months
of Skillshare for just 99 cents
Skillshare is offering my listeners
again two months of unlimited access to
all of their classes to 18,000 classes
for just 99 cents and once you subscribe
you're gonna want to continue
subscribing and continue learning to
sign up go to skills shared comm slash
Shapiro again that skill shared comm
slash Shapiro for the special offer to
get those two months now for just 99
cents that skill shared comm slash
Shapiro that also lets them know that we
sent you of course which always helps
the show as well so check it out skill
shared comm slash Shapiro okay so in
other big news over the weekend bigger
news probably than this then this March
which was in which was helped out by a
bunch of organizing groups which was
fine stormy Daniels obviously is the big
news of the weekend so her interview on
60 minutes was put off for a little
while by the Duke Kansas game which Duke
lost and stormy Daniels finally comes on
and then there is a 60-minute interview
with a very long interview it's not at
all 60 minutes with the Anderson Cooper
on CBS's 60 minutes and and things got
kind of crazy so there are a bunch of
things that that store McDaniel said
that were pretty wild
we knew most of us okay so to start off
we knew most of this right so most of
the stuff that we knew about stormy
Daniels we already knew stormy Daniels
for those who don't know is the star of
movies like The Witches of brest wick as
well as watching Samantha secrets of the
velvet ring what's a girl gotta do I
know what you did last night
and porking with pride too so she is
just you know she's one of the great
actresses of our time ron jeremy on the
loose atlantic city is one of her
classics of course busty beauties two
dripping wet sex 4 and she's really
she's she's class I mean she's all class
and one of the things about her that is
worth noting is that she she I will say
she has better script taste than half
the stars in Hollywood because the only
two legit movies I can find her in are
the 40 year old virgin and let's see
what was the other one it's the 40 year
old virgin and knocked up so she's in
and she's in both of those she plays him
on a lap dancer and in one a porn star
so I guess that's typecasting a little
bit I guess you wouldn't expect her to
play like the the female rocket
scientist but in any case maybe stormy
Daniels is secretly brilliant I tend to
think the pointing that stormy Daniels
is
pornstar and that she does things that
porn stars do like she has sex with men
for transactional reasons now listen
does it does make less Trump the Trump
less scummy now the president when it
comes to women is gross I mean this is
unquestioned and people who do question
that are being stupid Donald Trump with
women is a pig okay he's been a pig all
of his life this is a man who said that
avoiding STDs in the 1970s was his own
personal Vietnam at a time when he could
have been drafted in was climbing bone
spurs in his heels he was in fact off of
his heels for a variety of other reasons
Donald Trump is a guy who said that it
does nothing in life matters as long as
you've got a young and beautiful piece
of ass on your arm as a man who's had
three wives and cheated on all of them
usually with a future wife I mean I
suppose that we should consider
ourselves lucky that stormy Daniels
isn't the current First Lady of the
United States considering Donald Trump's
actual record here hey Donald Trump is a
guy who was caught on tape saying that
he grabs women by the bleep okay Donald
Trump is yucky with women this we know
and criticizing stormy Daniels for this
public display is not exactly letting
Donald Trump off the hook Hey other
things that are worth noting about these
situations so here's the situation back
in 2006 storm McDaniels met Donald Trump
at a golf course Donald Trump was doing
some sort of event and she flirted with
him and then she went up to his room for
dinner and then she had sex with him
I guess one time in the hopes that he
would put her on the apprentice and then
he'd not in fact put her on the
apprentice but he continued to flirt
with her by phone I guess the second
time that they met she went up to his
room and they watched Shark Week no joke
like that's power play mr. president
bringing the woman back up to your room
bringing the stars of forest bump up to
your room and in watching Shark Week
it's it's it's a move
I guess that move did not end up working
but then so stormy Daniels claimed a
couple of things in this interview she
claims in 2011 that after she gave the
news to In Touch magazine that she had
had an affair with the president why
InTouch even thought that was newsworthy
is beyond me apparently they didn't
think it was that newsworthy they
offered her like 15 grand for it but in
any case she says that she says that she
was approached in a parking lot by a
random dude and that the random dude
said to her that that he she had her kid
with her and he said it would be a pity
if something happened to that kid's mom
I threatened her about the intouch story
shouldn't provide me substantiation she
didn't you know provide a description of
the guy
we'll find out maybe more about that
then she claims that in 2016
she was paid off by Michael Cohen who
was the president's lawyer for 130
dollars to keep her trapped did to keep
her trap shot right before the election
she signed she took it and then she lied
about having an affair with the
president she said no I didn't have an
affair with the president well she had
to explain all of that to Anderson
Cooper now she claims of course she's
being threatened by the president in
some sort of nefarious way what she's
really being claimed what she's really
being threatened with his violation of
the non-disclosure which is perfectly
legal right the only part here that
there are two things that that are
legally questionable well that would be
illegal if they happen one is storming
Daniel's being actually physically
threatened by someone that obviously is
illegal and the second is of Michael
Kohn was giving a quote unquote
in-kind contribution to Donald Trump's
campaign by paying stormy Daniels out of
his own pocket to keep her silent so
this is a very weird interview because
stormy Daniels starts off by talking
about why exactly it is that she was why
she's doing the interview in the first
place so you turn around and pull his
pants down well you know he had
underwear on and stuff and and I just
gave him a couple spots you you were
special
you remind me of my daughter you know
he's like you're smart
beautiful and a woman to be recognized I
like you I like you you know don't worry
about that we don't even we have
separate rooms and stuff did you two go
out for dinner that night
no you had dinner in the room yes what
happened next
so I excused myself and I went to the
the restroom you know I was in there for
a little bit and came out and he was
sitting you know on the edge of the bed
when I walked out perched and you had
sex with him yeah I remember arriving
and he was watching Shark Week he made
me sit and watch an entire documentary
about a shark attack it wasn't at that
point of business meeting it was just
watching Shark Week
yeah did you have sex with him again
yeah I was in a parking lot going to a
fitness class with my infant daughter I
was taking you know the seats facing
backwards in the backseat diaper bag you
know getting all the stuff out and a guy
walked up on me and said to me leave
Trump alone forget the story and then he
leaned around and looked at my daughter
and said it's a beautiful little girl
would be a shame if something happened
to her mom and then he was gone
okay so let's go through some of this
stuff okay so first of all the actual
interview starts with Anderson Cooper
asking why are you doing this right he
says I guess I'm not sure 100% of why
you're doing this and she says
was very important for me to be able to
defend myself and he's leading her the
whole interview Anderson was really
giving her leading questions like is
part of wanting to set the record
straight
can I just tell her that part of it
isn't letting to set the record straight
and then she says people are just saying
that whatever they wanted to say about
me I was perfectly fine saying nothing
at all but I'm not okay with being a
made out to be a liar or people thinking
I did this for money and people are like
oh you're an opportunist you're taking
advantage of this yes I'm getting more
job offers now but tell me one person
who had turned down a job offer making
more than they've been making doing the
same thing they've always done um
she's doing it for money I mean I like
sorry I put this out again this story is
really not about stor McDaniels about
the President of the United States being
disgusting I mean he's the one who chose
to to put his thing in you know to to to
act inappropriately with stormy Daniel
shall we say to put it mildly okay this
is the President of the United States
his fault he's an idiot and he's
disgusting when it comes to women have I
made that clear if I said that enough
times he's gross yeah I don't find the
President activity here even mildly
defensible but here's why what did you
objective media are trying to make
stormy Daniels to be some sort of victim
okay unless she was actually physically
threatened if she was physically
threatened she's a victim other than
that there's no victimization story here
she took $130,000 from the from a
candidate for president of the United
States to keep her mouth shut and then
she didn't shut up okay and stormy
Daniels also said that she had
consensual sex with Donald Trump so this
is not a me-too moment now what's really
amazing is there are some people on the
Left who are trying to make it into a me
to a moment and again I'm happy to
discuss all the legal ramifications of
this and maybe a campaign finance
violation I don't think it'll take down
Trump because you really have to prove a
lot to prove a campaign finance
violation and I can talk about the legal
standard and all that in just a second
but when stormy daniel says that when
the media try to make her out to be some
sort of a heroic figure it just doesn't
wash it just doesn't wash of course she
came out after the election cycle
because her story was newly valuable and
it's worth more than a hundred thirty
thousand dollars so she figures okay
fine I'll give him back 130 grand and
I'll make five hundred grand by talking
about all of this stuff publicly but she
probably is it I mean again she is
transactional in this whole thing right
she said in this interview openly that
she saw her sex with Trump as a business
deal she was asked did you want to have
sex with Trump she said no she said that
they said were you attracted to Trump
she said no they said what why'd you
have sex with Trump and she said well I
saw it as a business deal meaning that
it was like she want to get on the
apprentice and she thought maybe this
would give her the possibility of
getting on the apprentice and sex isn't
exactly something that she is
that she's that she's stingy about so
all right but now what's hilarious is
the left is trying to make this into a
meaty moment I've seen a couple of
articles about stormy Daniels was
victimized by the power of Donald Trump
okay no she was not up until the point
where a threat was made
hey up until that point she's a lady who
knew that she was sleeping with a
married man in order to get ahead in the
business and this does raise some issues
about the nature of the meats you
movement in Hollywood as well because a
lot of the talk and the meats you
movement in Hollywood has been about
young actresses having sex with older
directors in fully consensual manner and
then suggesting that the power imbalance
is the real problem well as it possible
that they saw the sex the same way that
stormy Daniels did and she didn't really
want to have sex with Trump but she also
knew that if she wanted to get ahead
that she liked storming Daniels herself
said it was consensual
she never accused the president of
sexual assaulters or sexual or sexual or
a rape of any sort and so again the the
attempt to make stormy Daniels into the
hero of this story doesn't work I think
you can make Trump into the villain of
the story I think that it's hard to make
stormy Daniels into the hero of the
story where she's clearly not the hero
I'll talk a little bit more about this
in just a second but first we're gonna
have to go over to Daley we're calm and
subscribe when you go over to Daley
wired.com and subscribe you get the rest
of this show live you get the rest of
the Michael Mills show live you get the
rest of the Andrew Klavan show live plus
you get this mug when you get the annual
subscription so for $9.99 a month you
get you get all those things with the
annual is $99 a year which is cheaper
than the monthly and you get this
magical tumbler which is just glorious
anyway you get all that stuff you want
to listen later for free go over to
iTunes SoundCloud Google any of those
subscribe Luther review we always
appreciate it we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
so again as I'm fond of saying two
things can be true at once in the stormy
Daniels interview Donald Trump can be
disgusting also as I say it is not on
evidence that Donald Trump would have
people threaten people in fact they're a
bunch of accounts that are put out there
by BuzzFeed news BuzzFeed has a long
story about how in the 1980s there are a
bunch of threats surrounding Donald
Trump
they've tweeted out a series of these
threats including there is one that in
which a guy who called him his name
carmine said called up somebody who was
going to I guess sue Trump over a real
estate issue - my name is Carmine I
don't know why your effing with mr.
Trump but if you keep effing with mr.
Trump we know where you live and we're
gonna and we're going to your house for
your wife and kids that's according to
one caller on April 20th 1982 according
to FBI records one person called the
Newark Police Commissioner reporting
that he received a call threatening his
life over an abatement in rent by Trump
the call or the FBI records state became
very abusive and profane regarding
Lehman's inability to approve mr.
Trump's request for a tax abatement
Donald Trump's security guards once
Trump threatened and held a 12 year-old
boy and his mother against their will is
the allegation after her husband
promised to go public with damaging
allegations against the Trump
Organization again is is thuggish
behavior foreign to to Trump's
organization no and that's really what
this is going to come down to when you
boil all of this down when you boil all
of this down what it's going to come
down to in the end is whether Donald
Trump had his people threaten stormy
Daniels that's the only added element
here the reason people are watching this
story as opposed to the thousand other
stories about the Trump administration
is because there's sex involved with the
porn star obviously that's gonna be kind
of titillating for for the American
public and that's why they are
interested on any level at all but the
only way that this story actually gains
some sort of legs beyond just the
general interest is if it turns out that
Donald Trump actually sent somebody to
physically threaten stormy Daniels in
that case then you're talking about a
real scandal if it just turns out that
it's his lawyer paid somebody else to
shut up I'm not sure that's a big enough
scandal to take out Trump again Trump
abides by my strong markets efficiency
Theory everybody already knows what they
think about from good or bad and there's
not a lot of evidence that this is going
to stick to them now that's not gonna
stop a lot of people on the left from
claiming that this is gonna take down
the president but look even Anderson
Cooper had to go out
restore me Daniels's lawyer and point
out that that Daniels's lawyer is a
former Democratic operative you seem to
be saying that she has some sort of text
message or video or photographs or you
could just be bluffing you should ask
some of the other people in my career
when they've been on me bluffing in
college in law school you did opposition
research for democratic political
operative rahm emanuel some people
looking at that will say you're
politically motivated I haven't done
anything in politics in over 20 years
but this is not the usual case you take
on you are former Democratic operative
and you're talking about deposing the
president that sounds political
no it sounds righteous okay it doesn't
necessarily sound righteous unless
something righteous is actually going on
here
and avoiding an agreement that you
signed and I isn't exactly righteous
activity again I keep coming back to
this the only thing I think that matters
in this entire storm Daniels story is if
Trump send somebody to threaten her or
if there's a national campaign finance
violations those are the only two things
those could be the egg story but we
don't have the evidence that those
stories are true yet and store McDaniels
hasn't identified even the person who
threatened her with Trump himself so
we're gonna have to find out more about
that listen is it gross for the country
that we're at this point of course it's
gross for the country that were at this
point and I do find the the lack of
memory irritating on the part of some of
the media who don't seem to recall all
the way back to the 1990s when when Bill
Clinton was lying repeatedly about sex
and the same members of the media who
are currently batting Trump around for
lying about sex we're saying well
everybody lies about sex oh it's no big
deal remember all of the talk about
perjury all of the all of the criminal
charges that were brought against
President Clinton and Clinton in the
impeachment hearing by the house in
which he was actually impeached all that
was brushed off by the media as he only
lied about sex so who cares well I guess
here they would they they're not gonna
argue he only threatened about sex or he
only signed an NDA about sex so who
cares they're not gonna do that because
obviously it's Trump but is it a sad
state of affairs that this is the
character of our public officials yes is
it sad that the American people accept
this yes is it pathetic that the
President of the United States engaged
in this sort of behavior and may
continue to engage in this sort of
behavior yes it makes you sad for the
Republic it does I mean the Oval Office
was once occupied by people like Ronald
Reagan it was once occupied by people
like Calvin Coolidge was once occupied
by people like Abraham
and now I guess it was built after
Abraham Lincoln but in any case the
White House was occupied by Abraham
Lincoln but you know bottom line is that
the character of the country has
declined rather markedly when it comes
to these sorts of matters and and Trump
is more a reflection of that than a
catalyst toward it okay now in other
news the Trump administration is still
is still sticking with this whole tariff
nonsense the stock market has been in
serious trouble for a while if you look
at the Dow Jones Industrial Average it
dropped 14 hundred points last week it's
up pretty significantly today it's up
about 430 points today but it's been
incredibly volatile one of the reasons
for that is that the president keeps
going back and forth on all this tariff
talk now one of the things that's
happened inside the Trump administration
is that Trump seems to be gathering
around him people he is more comfortable
with so he wasn't quite as comfortable
with some of the some of the people you
know previously he wasn't super
comfortable with HR McMaster as the NSA
he wasn't super comfortable with with
with Rex Tillerson as Secretary of State
now he's surrounded himself with people
who are going to try and smooth off his
round his harsh edges by catering to his
stick and so for example john bolton is
the new NSA or will be the new SNA new
NSA and john bolton is is now speaking
out in favor of china terrace no I don't
think that Bolton is in favor of tariffs
but Bolton is gonna pitch the tariffs as
a way of negotiation because he
understands that if you go into Trump
Neutron called Trump no Trump's first
reaction is to immediately respond
negatively to you right Trump doesn't
like no men Trump likes yes men he likes
people around him who'll tell him what
he wants to hear and the key with
manipulating Trump it appears from the
officials inside the administration is
to tell him yes but right yes and yes
mr. president the tariffs are a great
idea and if you use them as leverage to
get a better trade deal with China to
get them to lower their trade barriers
then that would be great
and so yes and is a better strategy
inside the administration then no he
knows a good strategy for all of us we
have to call balls and strikes and you
have to tell Trump when he's being
stupid but if you're inside the
administration and you're trying to get
Trump to do the right thing I'm not sure
Bolton's tactic here is completely wrong
so here's Bolton talking about China
tariffs the United States believes by
these agreements I can tell you we've
got lawyers all over the government who
spend a lot of time policing American
conduct so that we uphold the
obligations that we make when we enter
into
a treaty all we're asking for here is
for the Chinese to do the same so I
think this could be a little shock
therapy get their attention and and
hopefully it'll have a good impact
okay so Bolton here is trying to make
the case to trump that these tariffs
should only be temporary and again I'm
not sure that this is the wrong strategy
again yes Ann might be the right
strategy Siva Newton was doing the same
thing over at the Treasury Department
I assume Larry Kudlow will be doing the
same thing in his new position as head
of the National Economic Council telling
Trump yeah your tariffs are a great idea
but you know it'd be even better you
know that's a great idea and what'll be
great is when everybody decides to come
to the table and we get rid of all the
tariffs altogether right use it as
leverage as opposed to I just don't like
these countries so we're gonna tariffs
them this is it's a significant
difference in policy I'll explain in a
second here's minuchin talking about how
tariffs really won't impact the economy
in any real way now this is stupid what
he's about to say to press my point are
the markets wrong to be afraid of the
president's tariffs and the impact it
will have on the economy I don't expect
to see a big impact on the economy we've
been very careful and how we're doing
this and and what we're doing but again
I think what we're doing is long-term
very good for the economy which it is
pressing for free and fair trade okay so
all right again he's trying to push for
the idea that this is an aspect of
leverage hey now these are two very
different views of tariffs Trump is
suggesting one view and his people are
suggesting another and we'll see who
wins out whether they're able to
convince him Trump thinks that tariffs
are in and of themselves good he
believes because he's wrong that if we
just tariffs Chinese goods the goal is
not to get them to lower their trade
barriers to American goods the goal is
to actually harm their economy because
the economy is a zero-sum game so if we
tear if there are Goods and make the
prices higher on their goods this
inevitably builds up in American
industry that is important and valuable
and American industry will boom again
it'll be just like the nineteen fifties
in terms of manufacturing and all this
nonsense
his people are saying something slightly
different and they're trying to kind of
sneak the the curve past Trump they're
trying to they're trying to move and
move inside and in that strike zone what
they're claiming is they're saying the
Trump look those tariffs can be a really
good way to push China around to
leverage China to lower their own trade
barriers then we can lower our trade
barriers China can lower their trade
barriers and then all the products will
freely flow we're gonna use this as a
measure of your negotiating skill mr.
president
that is not the same outcome right if
Trump follows his heart these tariffs
stay if Trump follows his advisors then
the tariffs probably go and this is why
it's sort of important Trump has
surrounded himself with and how cleverly
they approach the issue because if
they're smart they'll continue I think
to to massage the president's shoulders
and suggest that this is all great
genius and then sort of push him a
little bit toward the free trade it sort
of the free trade side of the market
well simultaneously telling them tariffs
are really good ideas Trump wants to
hear that he's a genius he doesn't want
to hear that he's wrong and so I think
all the people he surrounded himself
with know that or at least know him well
enough to know that that's how you
survive inside the Trump administration
okay time for a couple of things I like
and then some things that I hate so
things that I like over the weekend I've
been reading David Mamet's new book
Chicago it is a fun book to read ma'am
it has a real obviously one of the great
years for dialogue of all time there are
some characters who read easier than
others but it is a gangster novel about
about gangs in Chicago in the 1920s
there are a couple of historical errors
in it that were pointed out by a
reviewer over at The Wall Street Journal
but it's entertaining and again he
writes really snappy dialogue if you
like the untouchables then you'll like
Chicago David Mamet's new book check it
out it sits well with him by the way
David Mamet is a pretty outspoken
conservative in Hollywood which is a
rarity so he's well we're supporting you
for that reason alone hey other things
that I like so killer Mike who's a
rapper who I guess voted for Bernie
Sanders he is now defending the pro-gun
position he's actually making pretty
good case for it I have worked as a
tireless advocate on their behalf of
children disenfranchised women in my
community and I've also worked with gun
groups like George's against gun
violence that are not you know the the
most prone sector but I say if there's a
table to be said that the gun owner
needs to be there so I kind of try to
see a problem from the whole perspective
I got told my kids on a school walkout I
love you if you walk out that school
walk out my house we are we are a gun
owning family yeah we are a family where
my sister farms we're a family where
wheel fish will hunt but we are not a
family that jumps on every single thing
I our vows does because some stuff you
just don't agree with you know we are
raising a generation of kids where
everyone gets a trophy but
in real life everyone don't get a trophy
now you know in real life in real life
the cops don't come on time okay kill
them right making a good argument there
for gun rights and it is particularly
true at all it has always been true that
gun control in the United States at
least up till the 1960s and 70s was used
largely as a way of keeping black people
unarmed in the United States I think one
of the one of the things that the NRA
needs to do better is is speak out
loudly and proudly in cases like flan
toca steel flan toca steel had a
concealed carry permit apparently to
carry in the state of Minnesota he was
shot by police and that was a case where
the police were dead wrong apparently so
falando Casteel should never have been
shot in cases where there are black
folks who are being targeted because
they have guns that needs to be a major
issue for the NRA because own and guns
is in fact one of our most basic civil
rights and that holds true for people
across the color spectrum okay time for
a quick thing that I hate then we'll do
a federalist paper okay time for the
thing I hate so the thing that I hate
today the New York Times has a long and
stupid article about boys and girls at
preschools in Sweden who are being
coached in traits not associated with
their gender this article is by a woman
named Ellen Barry and the article is all
about how they're trying to achieve
gender parity in Sweden the way they're
going to do it is by teaching boys to
massage each other's feet and teaching
girls to walk around barefoot in the
snow and scream out windows no I am not
kidding
something was wrong with the Penguins
the incoming class of toddlers at the
seafarers preschool in a wooded suburb
south of Stockholm the boys were
glamorous and physical they shouted and
hit the girls held up their arms and
whimpered to be picked up the group of 1
and 2 year olds had in other words split
among traditional gender lines and at
this school that is not OK
can we stop right there first of all I
have a four-year-old and a two-year-old
they split along traditional gender
lines this is what they do not because
people are forcing them to but because
girls are girls and boys are boys and
because my girl who when she was very
little loved to play with trucks and
buses now will only wear princess
dresses no matter what every day she
will only wore particular headbands she
sent her clothes and her brothers
clothes every morning and my boy runs
around beating the crap out of
everything in a way that his sister
never did because boys and girls are
biologically different okay but here's
what they do in Sweden to try and fix
what goth hath brought their teachers
cleared the rooms of cars and dolls they
put the boys in charge of the play
kitchen they made the girls practice
shouting no then they decided to open a
proper investigation erecting video
cameras in the
classroom science may still be divided
over whether gender differences are
rooted in biology or culture science is
not divided on this okay okay this is so
stupid
science is absolutely unanimous gender
differences are in fact rooted in both
biology and culture pretending the
gender has nothing to do with biology is
insane okay no one believes this except
for radical transgender advocates
obviously testosterone in the brain has
an impact on how men act obviously
estrogen and development has an impact
on how girls act this is so incredibly a
scientific it is pagan crap okay it's
it's anti factual but the New York Times
obviously has to obfuscate the issue so
they say state curriculum urges teachers
and principals to embrace their role as
social engineers requiring them to
counteract traditional gender roles and
gender patterns in other words were
going to indoctrinate kids into feeling
uncomfortable about their own gender
because we're pieces of crap human
beings it's so funny the same people who
say empowerment self-esteem will say I
will train my little boy to act like a
little girl even if it makes him feel
uncomfortable so we can't make
eighteen-year-old snowflakes feel
uncomfortable for me to come speak there
but you can make my two-year-old boy
feel uncomfortable by forcing him to
wear a dress is stupid idiots and say it
is normal in many Swedish preschools for
teachers to avoid referring to their
students gender instead of boys and
girls they say friends or call children
by name play is organized to prevent
children from sorting themselves by
gender because we have to force kids to
do stuff they don't want to do amazing a
gender-neutral pronoun hen was
introduced in 2012 and swiftly absorbed
into mainstream Swedish culture
something that linguist say has never
happened in other countries it never
happened to any other culture or any
other country because no one was stupid
enough until now to try this his boys
are boys and girls are girls I love this
line exactly how this teaching method
affects children is still unclear
shouldn't that be the only question that
matters shouldn't the only question that
matters be how this affects the kids but
we don't care about that we care about
the social engineering and then they're
a bunch of beautiful pictures of all
these things happening love all these
things happening in Sweden I love this
drawing they showed a bunch of drawings
by students at the preschool when a
teacher noticed that girls were drawing
eyelashes only on girl she asked them
don't boys have eyelashes yes they do
but boys don't curl their eyelashes or
put mascara in them is one of the few
peer-reviewed efforts to examine the
methods effects published last year in
the Journal of experimental child
psychology concluded that some behaviors
do go away when children attend with the
study called gender-neutral preschools
for
instance the children of these schools
do not show a strong preference from
playmates of the same gender and are
less likely to make assumptions based on
stereotypes yet the scientists found no
difference at all in the children's
tendency to notice gender suggesting
that maybe under a genetic influence ya
think you think ok all of this makes no
sense the transgender advocates say that
kids know from the time they're two that
they're transgender but then they will
also say the gender is completely a
social construct so what the hell kids
that to know what a social construct is
none of this makes any sense at all and
then I loved it I love that they are
actually gender stereotyping they're
suggesting that boys like to walk around
barefoot in the snow so give your kid
frostbite give your little girl
frostbite to prove that she's just as
much of a manly man as the boys and make
the boys massage each other's feet first
of all foot massages should be illegal
in all 50 states
Peter gross objectively speaking and
making shoulder massage each other's
feet is unsanitary and yucky but
apparently they've been doing this for
years and years and years and years none
of this is designed to make children
healthier or better or develop better
all of it is designed to foster the the
virtue the virtuous feelings of leftist
who don't give a damn about actual
biology or science what stupidity I hate
this stuff because again manipulating
children is not my thing they do not
manipulate children they're innocent
innocent innocence is a code word for
having no moral to responsibility no
moral responsibility is why children are
innocent right what makes you in a sense
as a person is that you are free of sin
well make sure children in a census of
persons that they are free of sin but
children are free of sin because they
have no capacity to sin because they
can't make choices which means that you
really shouldn't be encouraging them to
make choices they're not qualified to
make or fostering situations where they
are uncomfortable for no reason at all
other than your own self glorification
you morons yeah ok time for a quick
Federalist paper back to the world of
reason Alexander Hamilton Federalist 21
we are all the way up there Federalist
21 so we're making steady progress
through the Federalist Papers this again
is a paper about more defects in the
current Confederate in the current
Articles of Confederation and he points
out three specific defects in the
Articles of Confederation they need to
be fixed by the Constitution first
there's no mechanism for the feds to
compel the states to do anything so if
you're in the middle of a Civil War for
example you can't actually compel the
states to do anything under the Articles
of Confederation that's a problem if for
example you're in the middle of a
foreign war and you need the states to
help out too there's no mutual guarantee
between the states so what that means is
that if the states go to war with one
another they can go to our
one another without the federal
government actually stepping in which
means effectively that the continent
breaks down into war and third there's
inequality of Taxation between the
states if the states pay into the system
directly rather than a system of duties
is placing on articles of consumption a
sales tax or a tariff one of the things
that's interesting here is that a lot of
the early republic was founded was
funded by tariffs because they had no
other option that's not what they
actually would have preferred in fact
Hamilton says that he'd prefer land
taxes but still they use tariffs one of
the things that Hamilton says in this
paper advocating for tariffs is that one
of the problems with tariffs is if you
make them too high people will just
smuggle which is a pretty honest
assessment of the situation it's also an
assessment the Left refuses to make
about taxation they raise tax rates
incredibly high and then they're shocked
when people avoid those taxes okay the
same is true of tariffs okay we'll be
back here tomorrow with much much more I
wanted to remind me Malthus I want to do
a breakdown of cardi B's rant on taxes
tomorrow because it's pretty spectacular
we'll do all that tomorrow I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by alexander o audio's mixed by
Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Joshua Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright floor publishing